the Lord will give the next talk on
first-order stochastic optimization
thanks David
and I would first like to start by
thanking David for all of his work in
this whole semester I guess I'm an
organizer but David really is the
organizer and he great work doing this
together oh thanks
so first order stochastic optimization
is a big broad general topic so of
course I can't talk about all of it in
an hour or two hours or a week maybe a
semester so what I hope to do here is
talk about some aspects of stochastic
optimization more leaning towards those
with applications and some of the deep
learning problems that are omnipresent
these days maybe throw out a few morsels
to get you to see some of these problems
from different perspectives maybe focus
on things like choosing the step size
when you run stochastic gradient descent
that I think are under emphasized in the
literature in general and I will focus
in explaining more detail results that I
was involved in just because that's what
I know the best but if you see
references during the talk I encourage
you to please go to those references and
also the references there in which site
and which are cited by to see the much
the much bigger picture and all other
results
so let's start with in general what is
optimization in machine learning say
today well a lot of problems in
large-scale machine learning our
classification we have a whole lot of
data maybe a lot of images we all have a
whole lot of data and the data is
labeled so here for example we have a
bunch of labeled data the first rows
airplane the second row or automobiles
the third row is birds etc and what do
we do with this we want to use this data
run it through some black box usually
some optimization algorithm which then
produces some classifier which when then
given image data in the future that is
unlabeled be able to automatically save
you know what is the label of this this
data so that that sounds complicated but
often the black box that we put the data
into to get out a classifier is an
optimization problem that has this form
minimize a so called loss function which
can be written as the average of many
many many component loss loss functions
and each component little L is
associated with one of the label data
points that we have so say one of these
images
so so this is a general I want to stress
that this little n is a very large
number in the millions so this is a big
loss function maybe 20 years ago what
would be a type of loss function that
people people could could study with the
computational power that was available
then would be sort of what's a basic
classifier which is a loss function
known as the support vector machine in
the simple case where the data that we
have the labeled data has either two
labels say plus one or minus one plus
one could correspond to the black dots
and minus one to the white dots we would
want to find a classifier in the form of
a vector W and sort of an offset scalar
B corresponding to the maximum
hyperplane that separates the label data
and does so in the best way in the sense
that it's a maximum margin separation so
the minimum distance to any of the label
data points on one side or the other is
as large as possible so this would be a
support vector machine notice that here
the loss function is nonlinear but
convex in this case that's convex and
can be written as in terms of a convex
optimization problem we have convex
optimization solvers and so if the data
is not too large we can just solve this
type of optimization problem directly
now a more modern example of an
optimization for machine learning is
these so-called deep learning methods
where we still want to minimize the loss
function which can be written as an
average of many component loss functions
but now each component loss function is
extremely nonlinear maybe taking the
form of many many products of
taking a weight matrix which is w1 w2 w3
let's just say in this simple example w1
w2 w3 our row vectors and we want to
optimize them in each layer we hit one
of our Rovers say w1 with the data point
at hand say x1 then apply a nonlinear
threshold often a simple threshold where
each vector each component is
thresholded to 0 or its component so
this is a so-called Ray Lu function in
DL next nuts and then this is repeated
over and over and over this is just
three layers of nested products but more
often people are using 50 layers or a
hundred layers of this okay this is very
nonlinear this you have to sort of lay
out an architecture of a particular
neural network corresponding to the
different layers and what is happening
in each layer to try to explain how you
go from the input which is the labeled
data to a classifier how can we solve an
optimization problem of this form well
if you look at this function very
nonlinear but it's possible to have have
a algorithm compute its gradient at a
point compute the gradient of a function
capital S using the chain rule so when
you have a lot of products of variables
you can use a chain rule so we can at
least write out what the gradient of the
loss function is at a point anything
more than a gradient is going to be
difficult and at the current state of
things not worth it in order to get a
better optimization algorithm so we're
gonna focus on first-order methods which
are iterative optimization algorithms
which only use gradient evaluations and
no
or order derivatives to optimize a
function I hope I've convinced you that
even computing a gradient of a function
like this is gonna take some work and so
I hope I've motivated the first order
part of the talk yeah there's a
non-smooth function l very like pepper
great yeah anyway that's a great
question uh no but we're gonna sweep
that under the rug for this slide yes it
has a sub gradient but no that's
a--that's a great question
but for this slide I'm just gonna gonna
sweep that so we're talking about a
first order method we're going to just
talk about the basic algorithm which is
gradient descent to start recall that if
you're at if you have a smooth loss
function so a function that does have a
derivative everywhere then if you're at
a point W then greedily at that point
the direction that you want to go to
which is the direction of fastest
decrease so the last function is the
negative gradient so the natural
iterative algorithm is that that's a
greedy iterative way of trying to find a
local minimizing point or a point where
the gradient vanishes is to just go at
each iterations some some amount in the
direction of the negative gradient that
lost function until you've reached some
convergence criterion like the norm of
the gradient small so I want to say
because in this talk I mean putting some
emphasis on the step size this alpha J
okay in this setting of gradient descent
it's not so much an issue of what the
step length alpha alpha J is a new step
for gradient descent in fact their line
search methods which say that we can
give you approximately the optimal value
at alpha J at each iteration which would
be like the steepest descent the one
that really maximizes the amount of
descent you have if you say I'm going in
this direction what's the best value at
alpha you can approximately get that
optimal value
and very very cheaply using like a
logarithmic extra number of derivative
steps using lionsearch
so so that's that's not so difficult
what is the problem in these large-scale
machine learning algorithms is the fact
that computing even even a single
gradient of the last function involves
computing the gradient in the direction
of the component function fi for all i
from 1 to little n by linearity of the
gradient and little n it's an order of
millions so we've been computing this
single gradient evaluation is not cheap
and it turns out that often it's the
trade-off is such that it's worth it to
instead do stochastic gradient descent
descent in quotes because it's not
necessarily descent deterministic leave
it rather an expectation so fast a
gradient descent is instead of computing
the full gradient of the loss function
at the current iteration which can be
expensive we're just going to randomly
select an index among our n component
functions or select a small batch
randomly of indices compute the gradient
only in the direction of that component
function or that batch of component
functions and just go in that random
direction at theis iteration so now we
have a randomized algorithm if we were
to plot the iterations of some run of
stochastic gradient descent even if our
loss function is nice and convex and has
one unique stationary point that's a
minimizer stochastic rating it's going
to get there in a bouncy randomized way
and if we don't decrease the step size
alpha J to zero it's gonna get into some
well around the point and bounce around
there forever so if you want to converge
for stochastic gradient descent we have
to take the step size to zero we'll come
back to that
so n is the number of components if we
if our loss function is written as an
average of little n component functions
[Music]
just at the top here so we're minimizing
a function of the form capital f of X is
equal to an average of little F IBEX and
I haven't give you said anything more
about what the FI are yet
is that clear the machine learning
setting can be think of it as the loss
function on the - yes in the machine
learning setting little F of I would be
the loss function on the ice data point
so if you have a selection of a million
labelled images that's each of the image
you would do this it's important that we
choose we draw component function at
random or at least to understand why we
do that it's so that in expectation at
each iteration we're going in the
direction of the negative gradient in
expectation this the direction in this
of a single component is an unbiased
estimate of the direction of the the
full gradient if just by linearity of
the Gullah gradient if we choose a
direction at random yep so the
topography of the space is determined by
the Train particular training set did
you have at that moment particularly the
the sharpness of the basin's
yes yes so that is let me let me talk
about this that that brings me to a
point I want it I wanted to talk about
in terms of the machine learning
application a decade or so ago we would
say or maybe even more recently than
that it moves very quickly that we're
not really trying to completely optimize
the loss function in machine learning
because you just want to get a point
that's close enough to the true because
what you really want to optimize is a
loss function over the whole universe of
data which you don't have what you have
is just a subset of of images out of the
whole universe of image and say so it's
enough to just approximately minimize
the the loss function and then that will
generalize even better than if you
actually minimize the loss function
completely which might lead to
overfitting when then you evaluate your
your classifier on holdout data so that
that was the perspective for a while but
now actually people in deep deep
learning has moved towards over
parameterize loss functions over
parametrization means the number of
layers in deep learning is so large that
the variables the dimension of the
variable W that you're solving for is
larger than the amount of labeled data
that you have n so you're solving an
underdetermined system in a sense so now
people say you really do a machine
learning want to optimize you're at the
population risk as a as they say you
really do what to go all the way to a
minimizer of it you're not going to over
fit and we're trying to understand why
gradient descent and stochastic gradient
descent methods seem to converge to a
special a special solution among the
infinitely many possible solutions of
the filter determine stochastic gradient
descent seems to converge to a solution
among the many solutions that has good
generalization property better than we
understand
but that's a different talk but I do
want to say that I think it's really
okay now to say that this is
optimization we want to optimize
optimize this function
okay so first I'll cast a gradient
descent in general we don't we're not
going to get a result about
deterministic convergence of the
iterations to a stationary point or a
local minimizer because it's a random
algorithm randomized algorithm so
instead we're gonna have results about
the say expectation of either the norm
of the gradient saying that goes to zero
at a certain rate or if we have really
nice properties like our loss function
is convex strongly convex smooth then we
might be able to say something about the
expected value of the l 2-norm
discrepancy going to zero at a certain
rate between our current iteration and
the unique global optimal solution so if
you look sort of a survey of different
theory for convergence of stochastic
gradient descent it's not very coherent
to be honest there are lots of different
results when you assume different
assumptions about your loss function in
your problem and that's sort of
bothersome and it really it's not just a
fact of that's just how life is
I hope in practice when implementing
these methods in machine learning
there's really no rule for in particular
how to Stew's the step size alpha J in
stochastic gradient descent and often
one manually Tunes this by hand for the
particular problem at hand that you have
in order to find the best values for
this and I'll get back to that but a
survey of some results are if your loss
function is smooth but not necessarily
convex then certain carefully chosen
value of constant step size or step size
decreasing like one over square root a
will give that the expected norm squared
of the gradient of the loss function
goes to zero like one over square root J
if the loss function is convex but not
necessarily smooth so it could have only
sub gradient but not
not gradient then again it's carefully
chosen choice of step size decreasing
like one over square root J allows you
to say something about the expected
distance of the loss function to its
optimal value going like 1 over square
root J if you assume stronger things
about the loss function that it's
strongly convex and smooth and each of
the component functions is also convex
then a very carefully chosen step size
value constant step size will give an
exponential convergence of the expected
l 2-norm discrepancy up into a
neighborhood of the minimizing point
sort of a neighborhood you reach a floor
where then you have just bounce around
this neighborhood and to see why you
have to do that is the step size is not
going to zero again then you're only
going to be able to get to within a
certain distance of optimum and then
bounce around so we're gonna talk about
about a couple of these different ones
so I first want to start with sort of
the theory that's nice yeah like C prime
exceed about fine law that constants no
yes and it's not very good notation
they're actually like very constants
that are carefully chosen to depend on
like the noise level annoys level and
the stochastic gradient the variance but
they're definitely a constant and not
something that's changing
yeah that's another confident yeah mad
yes that's a great word it is it's a
magic one so let's let me try to give
you some more detail about the magic
okay so the the setting where we have
sort of the cleanest shortest most easy
to explain and probably most illuminate
not illuminating but shortest proofs of
convergence are when we assume the most
about our loss function so if we assume
that each of the component functions fi
is convex if we assume that taken
together then the loss function is
strongly convex and that each component
function is has a gradient and that it's
gradient is Lipschitz continuous with
Lipschitz constant l okay so let me tell
you number two and number three just
think of this as the Hessian of the loss
function globally is upper bounded by
some largest eigenvalue L and lower
bounded by smallest eigenvalue mu so
basically we have this Hessian matrix
and globally we have an upper bound on
it being L and a that smallest eigen
value is lower bounded by Mew everywhere
so this you can understand why this is
going to be really nice it means that we
can essentially turn this into a linear
algebra problem where we have sort of a
continuous family of linear algebra
problems but they're all uniformly
bounded so in in particular when we have
a global upper bound of L and a global
lower bound of mu on the hessian we can
talk about the condition number of
optimization problem the optin
problem has a condition number that well
one notion would be l over mu that's and
then we can understand that the
convergence rate should depend on the
condition number of the problem as we
get better and better conditioned as
this number Kappa goes to one the
convergence rate should get faster yeah
we're gonna tell you into special alpha
star that depends on L mu that will give
you great great magical things yes
and now another component that
stochastic gradient descent will depend
on that say gradient descent would not
is something of the form of what's how
consistent are each of my component
functions and what they're minimizing
sets are okay so at in the case that we
have strong convexity that means there
is a unique minimizing solution X star
that we can talk about and at that
unique minimizing point X star what is
the average value of the norms of the
gradients of the component functions at
that point if that's zero that means
that the global minimizer of the loss
function is also a minimizer of each
component function separately okay so
that's really nice that's a consistent
system so the matte case Sigma squared
would be zero and we're gonna have
really good convergence in the worst
case the component functions are saying
we want to go to completely different
sets of the domain when you go in this
direction stochastic renate versus this
one that case Sigma squared is gonna be
big and we're gonna get confused and
stochastic gradient descent isn't gonna
converge as fast so these I hope I
convinced you both of these things are
sort of natural parameters that would
affect how well so house cranium does
they're not related
yes and I want to tell you that can did
the let's look at the example of solving
a system of linear equations this is
related to previous talks at this
workshop and all of these all of these
symbols that I'm throwing around you can
can really
place them in terms of linear regression
so if we want to solve a system of
linear equations so we have ax minus B
and we want to solve for X using
stochastic gradient descent in that case
each component function would just be
the inner product of the ice row of our
matrix applied to where we are X minus
bi and then squared okay so stochastic
gradient descent for solving or getting
a sort of least square solution to X
minus B would be pick a row of a at
random and then you know move in the
direction of that and then repeat pick
another row at random and so on so here
we have that the Lipschitz smooth is
constant from the previous slide is the
maximum l2 squared norm of the matrix
times n the strong convexity parameter
is going to be related to 1 over the
norm of the inverse of our matrix
squared so that the condition number L
over mu is close to the condition number
of a matrix except not quite because
it's L over the components the component
norms rather than the whole matrix and
the consistency parameter is well thing
which if our system of equations were
consistent if there existed a point X
such that ax equals B then the
consistency parameter would be zero
because ax equals B means that a I inner
product X equals B I for each I so
any questions at this yep for the strong
committee parameters are like all the
other ones have a factor n you know
there's a way to think of is there an an
associate with mu no because mu is the
strong convexity of the loss function as
a whole so the Lipschitz constant is
depending on some each component
individually so if you look at the ratio
of MU and he'll what you do right then
there's a factor and typically in there
or those typically within a constant
each other it looks like these should be
out by a factor of n which is enormous
well it's not because if all of the rows
of the matrix have the same norm then L
would be the furby Gnaeus norm of the
matrix would be the Frobenius norm
squared divided by the times the
smallest eigenvalue squared so it's sort
of like it it's very related to each
number but just for Venus instead of
spectral okay yes X starts a solution of
the least squares problem no not if it's
over determined that's the definition of
the solution of least squares age a
transpose times the residual that's true
but this is individually AI transpose
applied to AI so you're doing it
separately listen that capital a
transpose times the Rosetta
no little IRAs they - I X that I
transpose the IRA say alright I think
what you're saying would be true if it
was the norm of the Sun yes yes I agree
what if this were out here I think
that's true I yeah yeah no problem yeah
thanks for looking so carefully that's
this is all good and I also want to say
that if a is under determined because
that's very important to that there is
additional results where says ok then
you would be 0 but we can still get
convergence in terms of the minimal
nonzero eigen value okay so in fact this
I guess in this talk we're talking just
right here about strong convexity means
first system of linear equations that
the matrix is over determined but
actually there's a way to get around
that and also have the same thing for
underdetermined system just absolute
valley it's a scalar inside no nothing
that AI transpose is a vector being
multiplied by a scalar no but you're
right he's right but this is this
doesn't have to be a norm no your
Justin's right that this is a norm thank
you
Justin's always right and talks it's
kind of weird right like as uh okay
okay so a theorem about the convergence
rate of stochastic gradient descent
other the under these smoothness and
convexity assumptions that I listed is
that as long as you have a step size
that's constant a constant step size
also alpha as long as that step size
less than one over L L you can think of
as the the Lipschitz the maximal
Lipschitz component of the of the
component functions then we get this
decrease in the l2 norm squared in
expectation this is discrepancy - the
unique global minimizing solution that
has these two parts there's an
exponentially decreasing part that
decreases exponentially in J so as you
go along we're going to exponentially
decrease but then there's a second term
at the constant term that depends on the
consistency parameter Sigma squared so
what this says is we're gonna have two
phases in stochastic gradient descent
we're gonna have an initial phase when
we're very far away from the minimizer
where we're gonna converge very quickly
exponentially quickly if the step size
is chosen correctly and we have these
conditions until we get to a point where
this second the second term starts to
dominate when we're pretty close to a
neighborhood of the solution as given by
the consistency parameter and then our
convergence rate is going to is going to
stall out when we have constant step
size and if the consistency Sigma
squared is 0 in the best case then we
just get fast decrease all the way to
that solution that everyone agrees on so
everything's great and as it was
corollary to this we can actually do it
a calculus and solve for what's the
optimal step size alpha comfortable
constant step size to balance these two
terms if we fix off priori tolerance
term epsilon so we want to say I want to
get to it I want to get into a to be
within epsilon distance of the minimizer
tell me what step size I should take
this step size results in this number K
of iterations in order to get to
a point which has expected l2 norm
squared error less than epsilon so again
this K number of iterations depends on
two things the condition number okay so
it's our optimization problem is
well-conditioned this is close to one
that's great as long as it's bigger than
the second term the second term depends
on how how noisy our system is how this
consistency parameter
and I do want to mention that some
history into getting this result started
with a paper of stormer and version and
in 2007 on cash Moore's method for a way
of which is just stochastic gradient
descent in the case of linear
regressions or solving systems of
equations and they came from thinking
about these things I think as Ken was
mentioning Ruud Olson and version and
have their origins and high dimensional
geometry convex bodies so they they took
from that and if you're wondering where
we're going the next thing we're gonna
sort of talk about is doing a sort of
leverage for sampling in terms of
sampling rows of a matrix or components
component functions and our sum of
component functions the non-uniform way
in order to improve this this
convergence rate and that was inspired
by their their paper this is optimal yes
so this is optimal in the setting where
we have a certain tolerance that we want
to get to and then after setting epsilon
the tolerance then we solve for a good
constant step size in terms of getting
to that point as fast as possible yes
yes now you'd want to decrease the step
size if you don't want to preset a
tolerance okay so I'm running short on
time a bit so this is just to show you
that that the proof of this result is
this is it it's just a few a few lines
where we use all of the assumptions the
convexity the Lipschitz smoothness the
convexity of the components individually
and it's just expanding the discrepancy
between the point where we are and the
optimal point at iteration k plus one
expanding the square in a way to write
it in terms of the discrepancy at the
previous point
and then other inner products and and
norms because then we want to use this
to get a recursive inequality in terms
of that and now because the conditional
expectation so if we say we've gotten up
to a point XK at iteration K and now
just thinking about the randomness
involved in choosing a component
direction at that point to move to the
next point K plus one so if that's our
only source of randomness so
conditioning on that and we take the
expectation with respect to just the
draw of which which component direction
we take at that point then like the
expectation passes nicely through all of
these terms this is the only random
variable is the direction of the
gradient that we take at that at that
point and so the expectation passes
through it's essentially linear all of
the terms except for this last one which
we bound by the consistency parameter in
a way that then we get this recursive
formula for the expected value of the
air at k plus 1 given what the error is
at k and then we can apply the law of
total expectation to get all the way
back to a result about the expected the
total expected value the discrepancy and
so I say I as I alluded to we can
concoct simple examples to show that the
convergence rates are tight that we
can't hope to do something better in
certain situations so for example let's
go back to solving system of linear
equations suppose that our matrix a is
just this very over determined matrix
where its first row is 1 0 and all the
other rows are 0 and then 1 over squared
of n where n is the number of rows and
we want to find the vector 1 0 we want
to solve for the unique solution 1 0 2
the system of equations a times 1 0
equals 1 0 0 0 0 so if we run stochastic
gradient descent with blind uniform
sampling in this example it's sort of
stupid because you know with
ability almost won stochastic rainy
descent will pick a row 0 1 over squared
of n in a case it picks that row the
inner product of that row if say we
start at let's say we start it
yeah well we're it's just going to
project orthogonal to to the solution X
star so the stochastic gradient descent
update in this case is not going to move
at all we're not going to be able to
move at all unless we happen to sample
the first row 1 0 which will happen with
probability 1 over N so from that you
see that we need we're gonna need an
expectation n steps we're gonna have to
go through all of the rows in order to
pick a direction that actually gives us
any descent at all so from that we see
that the the Lipschitz the condition
number is n and that matches that we're
gonna need on the order of n iterations
so in really bad examples like this you
can see how sampling and stochastic
routine descent from a different
sampling component from a different
distribution as opposed to uniform can
really help in this example the first
row of our matrix is vastly more
important for the algorithm in terms of
choosing that direction than any of the
other rows so we would want to choose
that row with higher probability if in
an ideal world in order to to get to the
solution faster and this is a very
artificial example but in deep neural
networks there are classes of problems
that are very unbalanced like this in
particular in like text classification
when you have labeled text data there's
not no way to get around the fact that
certain letters of the alphabet are
gonna appear more often like E and T
they're gonna appear more often than Q
or Z and at a higher level certain words
are gonna appear more often than other
words and if those are your labeled your
labeled data then you're just gonna have
an unbalanced data set and there's no
way to get around that and so some of
the ideas here from this important
sampling are actually used when running
deep neural networks in in applications
to text images you can normalize
pre-process easier but text you can't
really
so I'll just say for stochastic readings
that with important sampling if we just
were a little bit more refined and
instead we look more carefully at each
of the component wise Lipschitz
constants so say each of our components
fi might have a very very different
Lipschitz constants some might be much
larger than others
delicious constant is like a curvature
how fast can the gradient of this
component change as we move from x1 to
x2 if it can change very quickly then
maybe we're getting more information
from that component benefit changes very
slowly and maybe we want to sample that
component with more with higher
probability okay so we might want to do
sample non-uniformly and when we have to
if we sample non uniformly we have to
then correct the step size in the
direction of that component we have to
set the step size to be alpha over
lambda i if lambda i is the weight with
with which we draw component by so that
our stochastic gradient direction is
still an unbiased estimate of the true
gradient direction
so we're still trying to solve the
optimization problem we have and not a
different optimization problem so
important sampling in stochastic
gradient descent also means you have to
change your step sizes depending on
which component or a batch of components
that you that you draw and it turns out
that a good choice of important sampling
weights are two sample component I with
probability proportional to the
Lipschitz constant of its gradient
divided by the sum of the Lipschitz
constants of the components one half
that and one half uniform still or some
other linear combination of that
weighted distribution and in uniform
it's important to have one part uniform
distribution still in there because
remember in stochastic gradient descent
the convergence rate depended also on
this
second term this consistency term and we
don't want to mess that up so in order
to keep that second term unchanged and
not a biased consistency term but Robbie
maybe in the nugget team right it's norm
squared sampling lengths towards my you
say like skaters in Victoria Li is the
norm in sale or norm squared yeah well I
was gonna mention that so here Li is the
norm squared so this is the norm squared
sampling that we've been talking about
in the past couple days in the case of
Li and storm understand and were the
ones to suggest that and then we
extended it from linear systems to some
of finite sum of convex yeah I have some
experiments yes yes it works it works
the experiments work just like the three
would say but I'm not doing the
experiments here because I don't like
that they the experiments use this
carefully chosen step size that depends
on parameters that in reality we're not
gonna have in advance but but but but
just as the theory says with these
weighted sampling the convergence rate
can in the worst case be improved by a
factor of n in the sense that the
convergence rate goes from depending on
the n times the worst Lipschitz
component to the average sorry that's
not true good from going and the worst
Lipschitz constant to the average
Lipschitz constant so like in this
example I showed before instead of
needing on the order of n iterations of
stochastic gradient to converge with
properly weighted sampling you only need
on the order of two or three as long as
you you know with the important sampling
we're gonna pick that first row with
constant probability and then we're
gonna be fine so it can the convergence
rate can improve by a factor of n when n
is the number of component functions and
they're the experiments this this this
is reflected in the experiment
yep um so [ __ ] is it the right thing to
think of the one over 1 over 2 n term
and it's like a regularizer or is is
that all face
oh maybe yeah I like that yeah
it definitely is hedging your bets if
you knew that your system was consistent
a consistent system so you could just
converge really quickly all the way the
solution you wouldn't have to worry
about the 1 over 2 n you just go fully
you know go fully there but head your
bets don't know which term is gonna be
more dominant in the convergence rate so
I'll just sample rows 1/2 according to
one and what 1/2 chorong the other
choose something from abuses makeup so
this one 0 yeah yes so that's what I
wanted to talk about what I wanted to
talk about let's see and so that's an
important thing is you know I'm
emphasizing here I want these results to
be of practical use and so we can get a
very large improvement in convergence
rate if we know these allies if we know
these Lipschitz constants of our
component functions so you're not gonna
know that a priori so there's a natural
question of if you're in the setting as
in deep learning where you actually go
through all of your your data several
times so in deep learning you can think
of it as these days being over
parametrized so an underdetermined
system of equations a nonlinear version
of that and an underdetermined setting
you go through all the rows more than
once in stochastic gradient descent so
you should be able to learn Lipschitz
constants as you go ok because you're at
least reading all the rows once so the
natural question is is there a way to
adaptively learn these lis maybe start
with uniform sampling go through one
pass to pass learn good say it better
sampling weights and step sizes and then
adaptively move more towards important
sampling and end up with a convergence
rate that's as close as it could be to
as if you knew what the Allies were
beforehand yeah so if I'm using this
with mini-batches GB though is the
little n the size of the mini badge yes
if you're using this with mini-batch
then little n is the size of the mini
batch and the L eyes are like the
spectral norm squared the spectral norm
squared of the batch the matrix of the
batch matrix I'm pretty sure I mean it's
it's a yeah and so I just told you this
theoretical question I guess I don't
know the answer I think it's a good
question so there's sort of two
questions one is can we you know learn
them in some sense in order to get a
convergence rate and then can we use
them to match the sort of magical
convergence rate as if we knew those in
advance yeah yeah as far as I'm
concerned it's an open question there
have been lots of work especially
recently demonstrating that empirically
there are methods for adaptively
learning the Lipschitz constants so that
when applied to deep learning problems
which are completely violate the
assumptions of convexity that I had
before for the theorem the important
sampling will allow the deep learning
algorithms to converge faster without
losing generality like the let me stick
a little bit
yes it's not whatever you said I would
argue that that's an even harder problem
because what you really want is to move
to do an important sampling that depends
on the local Lipschitz constant where
you are rather than the global ones yes
because maybe you have an opponent
function that has really high curvature
off in la-la land that we don't care
about so it's global if it's constant is
big but locally it's something else
completely you you want to use the local
information that's going to leave the
theory theoretically that's harder yeah
that's a good question I forgot in
theory if there it's an over estimate
then it's a stable result in the sense
that if you overrate overestimate the
Lipschitz constants by two there's just
a factor of two worse than the
convergence rate if you underestimate
you're toast
so if you if you underestimate then
maybe this light answers this question
but the had the impression that for the
nests GD sort of had a magical property
in the sense that the generalization
error is better and if you actually
optimize the empirical risk exactly and
there are various kind of results of
that nature that you it's not converging
see Karin really care about his
generalization so I sort of trying to
allude to this earlier that's um I think
people don't believe that anymore I
think that was the belief until a few
years last Monday in the last few years
the deep learning architectures have
become very over parameterize whereas
they had so when you have an over
parameterize system and there are
multiple possible exact solutions to
your optimization problem it seems
empirically that you really can drive
the population risk to zero and you
don't see any overfitting in your
generalization so then the question
isn't like ha you know whether we should
solve the population risk exactly or
approximately or whether SGD is magical
it's why does stochastic rainy descent
and maybe even also gradient descent why
does it converge to a minimum norm
solution among the infinitely possible
solutions so that's so that's the modern
way of thinking about it we can we can
prove that it will convert gradient
descent will converge to the minimum nor
solution when art we have a system of
linear equations because then it's very
trivial that you stay in a certain small
subspace you stay in the the row the row
span throughout all the iterations of
gradient ascent thus it must converge to
us sort of what do they say special
generalizable nice nice solution low
complexity solution so the question of
well how does that happen more generally
for non
linear problems is sort of where that is
right now did that yeah yeah speaking of
implementation are there any numerical
issues that there is here I saw some
ends of the denominators no there aren't
cuz the the sampling weights are sort of
theirs they're not bad they're one half
uniform sampling plus one half biased
sampling so you're never doing something
very singular like dividing by zero so
in practice you could say for current
ends throw a double precision at
everything yeah yeah yeah there's it
there's no dividing by some I should say
hey the price of don't want precision
everywhere yes yes yes yes um so I just
in the last couple minutes I want to say
that these questions of learning the the
Lipschitz constants I think is really
interesting but there's even a more
basic question that seems difficult
which is even without important sampling
just uniform sampling there's still only
a certain range of step size say
constant step size that will give you
convergence at all with std if you
choose a step size too big like greater
than one over L where L is the maximal
Lipschitz constant then you won't
converge at all stochastic gradient
descent will bounce around and even
diverge so even without important
sampling just plain stochastic gradient
descent choosing the good step size
depends on knowledge of at least the
Lipschitz constant of the problem which
we isn't gonna be no not priori it's an
interesting problem to say can we learn
it in a sort of one-pass way in a
streaming in a streaming sense
especially if all the components have
the same Lipschitz constant you can
imagine that that would be easier than
if each one has a different it was a
different one so I just want to mention
that that this is sort of a current
direction of research in stochastic
optimization the sort of making
stochastic optimization less dependent
on values of hyper parameters like the
step size how like how many of these
parameter
do we really need to set exactly in the
magical way in order to get convergence
can we put some dynamic update in the
algorithm itself to learn some of these
parameters and and so in particular for
if you just want to learn the Lipschitz
constant in stochastic gradient descent
then there are recent results showing
that some very simple algorithms which
just correspond to embedding and
updating sort of on-the-fly update of
the step size or learning rate just as a
running average of norms of gradients
that you've observed so far
or maybe norms of gradients you've
observed in the last so few many
iterations can be used to as an adaptive
update to a step size so that you can
get convergence rates for stochastic
gradient descent with this update rule
that are close to matching the auricle
rates which depend on tuning choosing a
step size carefully chosen depending on
the Lipschitz constant and this is this
atom this algorithm is called it's a
variant of a DES grad and so this is
used a lot in practice and training
neural network so stochastic gradient
descent so it's not an algorithm that I
pulled out of the air this is these
algorithms are used to make stochastic
gradient descent less sensitive to
parameters like the step size and
current results are giving giving theory
for that so I'm just gonna stop there
time for lunch
thank you
[Applause]
mention that important sampling was
useful for data with text that perk
integers you can normalize it away
explained so images what they do
currently is pre process images in the
training set pre-process the individual
images and the data set to be sort of
have the same l2 norm and same variance
which corresponds to essentially
balancing all of the the component
Lipschitz constants to be great close to
each other we need to pend more on the
imbalance in your classes though
like if you compared to that linear
regression you had one brow that was
different from it might be that's that's
a good point
they also balance that so in all of the
standard data sets that people write
machine learning papers on like CFR 10
and imagenet all like the sizes of the
different classes are very balanced as
well so now just because people do this
doesn't mean they should write so I mean
what we'd really like is for a neural
network to be able to take in streaming
training data not stuff that we've
heavily pre-processed
so so just because on the sort of
standard standard data sets that people
compare algorithms to just because
important sampling might not help on
that doesn't mean that it isn't useful
but you can't do the same type of
normalization with like a beneficial
thing No
sorry instead of going over the multiple
times and trying to their village and
keep you something they remember we were
tasting or access which it just Ronny
until it makes that
you don't need to learn all the legend
I don't really understand but I'd like
it maybe if you think you know oh I see
so you say choose a component function
and then stay on that component function
not just for one iteration but for many
iterations so that you can maybe I
should have added a caveat that um and
sort of the deep learning algorithms
they only do things that are pretty
simple they don't want to add extra
extra stuff to the algorithms because so
I don't know if maybe in accept/reject
like line searches are very ineffective
in the stochastic setting so that's
another sort of accept-reject way of
choosing the step size that they don't
use so I don't know
okay let's thank ritual
[Applause]